[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome to the ABS show so it was my
father's my pops is a scientist through
and through all he does is investigate
[ __ ] like in the past history making to
do with physics with with extinctions
what does the investigate light gravity
gravity physics in general as assists
but he also talked investigates a lot
about history right yeah
history I'm interested in politics no
longer but you've been investigating a
lot about the Neanderthals lately yeah
why did you start investigating the
extinction of the nfl's that was just a
question popped in your editor no I
started investigating extinction and I
started in general dinosaurs and earth
all there every all subjects which are
quite interesting for the majority of
people people want to know how the
dinosaurs became extinct out that
Neanderthals became extinct how the
woolly mammoths became extend you're not
satisfied with the theories that are
popular yeah and it's the physics in the
end it all comes back to physics because
relativists say that we're gonna do
forever essentially that's what they say
we're gonna get out of the planet we're
gonna go to another star system we're
gonna colonize the universe and and so
humans are immortal we are God's we're
not human and I'm saying we're about to
become extinct and so in order to arrive
at that conclusion you have to first
figure out how it is that the you know
previous species became extinct what is
the mechanism of extinction what is the
mechanism of mass extinction what is the
mechanism of a background extinction
that's how I got into the extinction
business and you start investigating in
the animals first I started
investigating the dinosaurs which is
topic
love and then of course this leads you
to wonder about the never thought how
did they become exempt because there's a
difference
the never thought the dinosaurs died in
a mass extinction lots of them died at
the same time the whole family the whole
order called dinosaur day they get wiped
out here we're talking about buying that
up through dating when everyone died at
the same time yeah I'll say
suddenly those bones are sublime the
later the rock and and so they see
something happened here and that's
that's the mass extinction but here we
have you know here's the woolly mammoth
he up the manned earth all you have
other animals like it will be right now
yeah right yeah you get all these and
the deer behind the deer the buffalo he
it's really the the ancestors yeah all
the ancestors are all these animals that
we have today of the cattle and so on
you know they up lived never again
and yes so he died all alone and so this
creates a big problem because he and
people have died in some kind of mass
extinctions as well you know something
happened you make a comment go out cops
of always you know something but yeah
it's Mother Nature singling out mammoths
on leaving everybody else alive almost
surgical yeah so she's so precise of all
leaves everybody else in there so this
creates a problem and the way they try
to solve this is by bringing man and
they say the ninety to ninety nine
percent of the theories out there have
to do with man causing the extinction of
the Nano those who either killed them we
out competed them or had more children
or whatever or we intermarried with them
which is the reigning theory that we
have what is called a mixture in other
words we interbred with an Ender
thousand because we were a much larger
population they kind of diluted their
gene pool in ours
wait it was a little late it's a little
pool in a in an ocean that's a change
they want to paint it so Neanderthals
what is it the Endor though some people
might not know well there's been a
different species they are not human
they're not human they're hominids what
we're saying here is if we look at what
we've bonds that we find in the rock
what they've found so far what's the
general picture the history that they
want to paint is that there was over two
million years ago we had this Homo
habilis Homo habilis is a very archaic
human that apparently gave birth to the
next major level which is Homo erectus
Homo erectus is the first human or first
hominid that stands on two legs okay and
this happened anywhere between two
million years ago to maybe 800 or 700
thousand years ago through a million and
200,000 years they have these hominids
ruled the planet they expanded cetera
not everywhere but they really extended
from like possibly and not confirmed but
very possibly from England all the way
to China so that whole stretch of land
and Africa by the way so that whole
stretch of land including Africa was
populated here and they're not
completely uniformly but here and there
and there were bands of these Homo
erectus these pre man men right these
are protohumans there's their brains
were smaller specifically the brain is
what they look at Nonnie and they don't
get the morphology other things but the
brain size you can see that it's growing
from Homo habilis through homo erectus
the next level is Homo heidelbergensis
Homo heidelbergensis apparently is born
in Europe his counterpart homo
rhodesiensis is born in Africa they both
apparently come from homo erectus in
other words Homo erectus in Africa
evolves into homo rhodesiensis
which is a level the same
approximately as Homo heidelbergensis
who descends from Homo erectus in Europe
okay
okay so we have eaten and then from
there humans descent from homo
rhodesiensis in Africa
yeah and Neanderthals Homo
neanderthalensis descends from Homo
heidelbergensis in Europe that's the
general picture he's a cousin of ours
yeah a long-lost cousin a distant cousin
but the same well well this is this is a
good question because what it all comes
down to is whether we belong to the same
species or whether we are to are simply
two different races of the same species
you know you have dogs yeah and you can
have a Doberman and he can have sex with
a German Shepherd they're differently
morphologic you can tell the difference
between a poodle and you know blood but
they can have offspring because there
are different races of the same species
and the question is the Nano those
belong to the same species as humans or
were you know where we the same species
two different races or were we two
different species could we have be able
offspring because with them that is that
we could have quite a lot of spring
that's basically opening the doors to
the said mixture theory that you
mentioned earlier where it's not that
the Neanderthals died off or they were
surgically removed or whatever it's that
they just bred with us and that's why
they're no longer to be found yeah in
other words the mixture theory the
interbreeding theory essentially holds
that they never disappeared which is the
most popular theory yeah right now yeah
because the degenerate geneticist got
into the business and they supposedly
proved that we had intermarried them we
enter bread with them and we are the
Neanderthals we have no authority no
that's that's the theory that they knew
disappeared they became us that's the
problem that's the theory that's the
problem
yeah okay so where do you start with
this what was the the part that it first
showed you
then something was wrong with this
theory what caught your eye a mother and
it like don't begin with the first
problem I've got is that again are we
the same species or are we just two
different races of the same species
that's that's essentially what's in the
back of my mind I have trouble with
interbreeding in a while because we
don't see that very at all really we
don't see it at all and again we have to
determine what we mean by species and
what we mean by race if you know it's
very unlikely that mother nature creates
the same species in two opposite sides
of the planet in two different
environments under definitions that can
still come back and interbreed if that's
very difficult to believe that humans
would be invented by mother nature in
Asia in Europe in Africa you know humans
and that we come back and we all develop
like independently and then we get
together me or can interbreed that's
very unlikely just doesn't know I don't
know you know it's very hard to believe
that that's what happened more than
likely you know humans were born
somewhere and I think they were born in
Africa they came out and then they
became all these different races and
given enough time it would have become
species in other words if we isolate the
Chinese from the Africans from the
Americans for a million years or
whatever
a hundred thousands of years then yes
when you put them back together they
can't breathe because - too much time
has passed and they've been subjected to
different environmental pressures and
that's I think what happened with an end
of those they were separated by maybe
around 500,000 years we're rounding
these numbers because they don't really
know that you got all these ranges for
when the Nano thoughts compared on the
face of the earth but let's use that
number 500,000 years that's a long time
and it's not so much the time time is
important yeah but more important is the
environment nano though develops in
Arctic Europe it's cold it's cold it's
freezing cold he has no clothes they
always paint him in clothes you go to
the museum they dress him up in
is it because he'd have no need for it
he had no need for it because we gotta
go back one step back the man of
Heidelberg he was already in Europe and
we have to go one step back man of Homo
erectus was in Europe and he was in
England in Arctic England how did he
survive the cold if he was you know
clothes have been invented so so what
they know what they do is they go back
and be trying simple oh yeah we think he
used clothes you know we're gonna go
back to the monkeys and say they used
blood sir how far do they want to go
homo erectus did not have clothes and he
lived in at some point there was someone
there those living without clothes
correct and so and and all of them were
without clothes Homo erectus Homo
neanderthalensis and Homo
heidelbergensis and Homo
neanderthalensis all three of them
throughout that whole period of time
they never saw clothes in their life
they lived with their bodysuit with what
mothers is really hairy they were hairy
they were hairy never thought was the
Arctic gorilla just like you have the
polar bear he's got this thick skin and
he can live there like you have wolves
they don't have as much you know fat
protection as the polar bear but they
live in the arctic weather comfortable
in arctic weather and never that was the
same thing he stepped on the foot on the
snow with his bare feet he didn't have
samples he it for him it was normal we
go there do it's hard
he didn't know what cold was he had no
idea what cold was so so here you have
the standard Nanda thought he's
completely nude hairy probably a very
lightly hairy or really fan and he had
his good protection of layer of fat he
was an arctic gorilla here comes human
he goes into this weather and he's
probably gonna be frozen to this so he
has to invent clothes I don't think he
could have survived in your without
clothes I'm gonna see they're used to
the Sun come on Africa they're born in
near the equator somewhere near the
equator they slowly move up north and
when
they start feeling Dakota sleep well I
better put something nice I shoulda just
turned around and got back to not my cup
of tea and that's and that's when you
start seeing so maybe the sewing needles
come later but that's around the time
that you start hypothesizing or
theorizing depending you make the
assumptions or you theorize that that
they invented clothes humans humans did
no never Nana those but humans must have
been bending clothes at some point in
time because they were moving into cold
weather but I guess it's straight the
homo erectus went all over the
continents yeah I would say England to
China and Indonesia let's say Africa in
America Africa a you raise your
regeneration yeah so we got Homo erectus
everywhere
pretty much but remember a sigh off in
China visibly in Asia he died off didn't
they don't make it for whatever reason
you're still unknown unless we killed
them - or admixture them - no no now
that we came too late they died off
eight hundred thousand years ago and
there's no hon there's no we came in
though earlier than a hundred thousand
years ago so
so we're seven hundred thousand years -
mate - killed alongside on them they
died off period but Homo erectus is this
is that went to Europe and Africa though
see Paul knows evolve to the next day
they went to the next stage they mother
entered the next or the next to it I
mean we men still separated remember we
made there's really no chopped yeah
there's no chopped
it's a it's a gradient continues but but
here we in a mansion but over there
there's no eventually the ones in Europe
died off yeah but while the ones while
the while we were still in Africa the
other guys still died off yeah you got
to explain how erectus died in in Asia
no matter what so right this dies in
Asia 700
thousand years ago how did he die and
wedding the wedding ended post went to
dinner and he has about forty thousand
years ago that's the big capacity Google
so what should we do with that Misha
paleontologists let me tell you what I
think
come on up
[Music]